they are human beings every person every
family that comes to live in fireplaces
must be feeling like new let's say
like a rebirth to feel like
each of us in
africa life is a coincidence but if you work on
something
they come and take everything
I always lost  every day I measure
alarm they shoot with god always afraid if
they don't have to fireplaces it
's okay the abandoned houses that
people not finding work not finding
we say anything in the country but thanks
we say to these emergencies that she
arrived here in chimneys little by little
we have taken this country
with  arrived in libya dangerous levels
home with in libya he did not tell me we
have boats years in italy he wants to
go that he brings immediately I went
with
him for three days the new ceo so he
all people move and the boring
pisa to concern all people mur
so this ep percolation from italy
to libya their career path i
work as a bricklayer and in
this cooperative with me there is al sun and
al  cie migrants we build these houses
to give other emigrants
the opportunity to live in these houses
that we are going to restore in sanna
arrived in july two years ago they are really seen by
the person who cares and is
attentive in the work and also helps
people like him to grow up in many
beautiful things and from there little by little he
built a
rapprochement with hassan day after day and now
we have another son for us I have to tell you
the truth
hello mar
only when I wanted to take him home
he told me here  today after every day
you don't think there is no my mum there is not
my house
no here at random you do as you like how they
went home what what but if these
different with them to have found themselves
home with but I do not speak with  them together
yes not which one above the people
passing by do not serve yes i am not
osmany cosman's son buy
those on horseback because here at my house
in siena it was then i'm happy happy and
for the horse i
wanted to go too  all the children of the
town
here I am I send back they weigh doors where there is
the weight then the children for a collapse
above also the children go up on all
but happy happy
when I talk about hassan from the boe spontaneous love
in fact made me even a  he can
cry because he finally said I
am in a country where there is another
mother and another father who deserves a
lot of satisfaction to
have that now sanna is part not only
of my family
but of a big family let's say
friends
in the  life you know where it stops here and
help Christians to do something and
saints nicholas which not to make a
crisis only are the world
the questions were in your god it's not
all
in the sun the first thing i told him i
will always repeat until  to
death to always help people in
need as we did with
him
I believe that he will realize and do a
lot for this
country too  i can feel my my wife
humans